good morning John 2080 three days ago I
met a video and I put it up on the
vlogbrothers channel and then a day
after that you uploaded your first video
to a different channel because we didn't
understand how YouTube works since then
a lot has happened to us and to the
world you got a new baby I got a new dog
we got the last Harry Potter book we got
a new president we found a new
fundamental particle of physics our
videos went from sort of disgustingly
grainy 240p all the way up to crisp
beautiful 1080p on you and i we made a
thousand videos and john that is amazing
I am proud of us that's an amazing
number but it's not the most amazing
number each one of those videos has been
watched an average of 250,000 times for
a total of a quarter of a billion views
if all those videos were watched all the
way through which of course they weren't
because some of them are pretty silly
that would be 1500 years of human life
spent watching our videos and that is
the number that I would feel bad about
if I didn't feel like we had actually
done some pretty cool things with that
time $300,000 raised and thousands of
videos produced for charities through
the project for awesome thousands of
bracelets sold for this star won't go
out over 1 million dollars loaned
through the nerdfighter group on
kiva.org hundreds of deep thoughts from
dozens of places and tongue blogs full
of gifs or gifts whichever you prefer we
spent all of that time embarrassing
ourselves or doing nasty things to
ourselves which I do not regret in the
slightest you took advantage of your
son's cuteness angry we're never gonna
go viral unless you bite my finger I
took advantage of my Doug's der penis I
sang songs about Forks and ponies and
Harry Potter and Helen Hunt Ellen hunt
tweeted to me about my song about her I
invented 2d glasses and turd Pride and
Prejudice into a video blog who went on
tour Katherine and I beat Super Mario
Brothers Wii U and the Swindon Town
smoothly poopers won the ethic telly
myth we've been on the front page of USA
Today of the New York Times and more
importantly of Reddit we made new things
that we could never even have conceived
of without the support of this community
the foundations that agree swirled Zuk
is a real nonprofit now we've started
educational channels that both have more
than
200,000 subscribers he started a record
label and a web series and a conference
I got to sing a song with George Watsky
and Felicia Day he made friends with
really remarkable and talented people
from all over the world
we've helped create and define this
creative community that I think is bound
for really amazing thing almost every
video has been a joy to make and every
one has been a joy to watch and in all
those years I have never missed a
scheduled day of vlogbrothers in you
John you've only missed one and I
forgive you because you were in the
hospital I'm sick that's my IV fourth
there's a lot of numbers in this video
because I'm trying to quantify something
that can't be quantified here's the
number two it's the number of brothers
who are the luckiest brothers in ever so
thank you all for that thank you if you
ever watched a video or participated in
a project or donated to any of the
charities that we have supported thanks
for helping us be better people and for
traveling with us on this journey and
John and I will continue to do our best
to not let you down and to make great
content that you like watching and also
to try and make the world a better place
John auto power off are the